[Music]
[Applause]
more phone calls coming up brian greasy
former nfl quarterback espn monday night
football analyst he'll be on the call
with lewis riddick and steve levy monday
night playoff football it'll be the
cardinals and the rams brian good to
have you back
um biggest question mark you have going
into this cardinals rams game is what
yeah is will they will the cardinals
then be able to handle aaron donald um
they were not able to handle him in the
second meeting uh and it was a big
reason why kyler murray felt a lot of
pressure and and had two interceptions
in that game and that that was the
difference in the game uh they they were
driving early uh they had a tip from
aaron donald intercepted by ernest jones
no points and the rams go right down and
score and then to start the second half
um they had a great play from leonard
floyd tipped interception um and that
pressure on tyler murray on the field i
think impacted him now you could also
wonder and the question is about the
pressure on kyler murray off the field
first playoff game in his career there's
been a lot of time energy uh and effort
put into building this team by steve kim
they're finally in this position it's
not where they want it to be
as a wild card team i remember about a
month ago this was the number one seed
in the nfc and they're kind of limping
in losers of four of five so how will
they respond to the big moment also is a
question for me but when you have
pressure up the middle and you're kyler
murray
how different is that pressure up the
middle in your tom brady
well i think the the the approach for
raheem morse the defensive coordinator
for the rams number one is to try to
keep kylo murray in the pocket um so
it's very i mean it's completely
different than tom brady tom's gonna be
in there you know where he's gonna be
um kyler murray you know job number one
is keeping him in the pocket because he
is dangerous and he will beat you
outside the pocket they were they had
mixed results with that uh this year
um but when he gets outside the pocket
he can hurt with his legs uh more than
anybody in the league and uh and so what
i think the rams have with von miller
and leonard floyd up on the on the edges
uh is is good enough to contain him and
then you add in aaron donald on the
inside that's what's unique about the
rams pass rush and that's why they were
successful in the second meeting
how would you grade matthew stafford's
first season in la
uh
i write as of right now i'd say it's
about a b
and uh listen this team won the nfc west
nobody's giving them that kind of credit
they won 12 games um really his grade
will be dependent upon what happens in
the next month didn't they have a b
quarterback already brian
no i wouldn't say that i would say they
had a b minus c plus quarterback and
jared goff
um so i think there's no doubt they have
upgraded the position and matthew
stafford has made some unbelievable
plays and won them games dan
now he's also you know been careless
with the ball and he's tried to make
plays when they weren't there um and and
so as they get into the playoffs they
need to take a little bit off of matthew
stafford's plate run the football and
then when the play is there to be made
we know that he has the ability to make
yeah i wondered if matthew stafford was
trying on almost every play i want to
prove to everybody it was detroit that
was the problem not me i was there
didn't win a playoff game 12 years hey
let me get on a winning team and i'm
going to show you
and and maybe he got out of his comfort
zone a little bit and you know but you
have four pick sixes how do you explain
that 17 interceptions four of those were
pick sixes is that just
you know by luck by chance
no i think it's a quarterback trying to
do too much i think you're right um you
know i think this is a team that not
only
do they feel like they have to win
but dangerous for them they feel like
they have to win with style
and and that's not listen we're not
talking about the san francisco 49ers
like that they don't care how they win
they just want to go out and win but the
rams being in la got a lot of bright
shiny toys uh and and the first half of
the season couldn't have gone any better
uh in the marriage between sean mcvay
and matthew stafford you got the best
receiver in the league in cooper cup i
got odell out there and you and you want
to have some style you want to have
pizzazz and i think that matthew
stafford from time to time call it five
six seven plays a game will force the
issue and that's where he's got into
trouble and i i don't think that he
needs to do that for them to win
pro football focus released its ranking
top 10 nfl players to start a franchise
with 2022.
number one on the list
patrick mahomes
number two on the list
who would you pick
start your franchise with in 2022.
you know it'd be hard i'd be
hard-pressed to um to pass up josh allen
or joe burrow
those are two of the joe burrows top
quarterbacks joe burns
those are two of the top quarterbacks in
my opinion uh young quarterbacks in the
league justin herbert is three josh
allen four
great argument for justin as well um
you know any one of those three in my
opinion um you could build around uh
listen i'm excited to watch now we're
gonna find out about josh allen and joe
burrow here in the next the next week
and a half two weeks
um you know josh allen playing bill
belichick for the third time uh in a
season can't wait to watch that and joe
burl's first opportunity and listen i
know that you know the the raiders have
kind of squeaked their way in but
that'll be a challenge for for joe
burrell so uh yeah i wouldn't disagree
with any of those okay i'll continue
this kyler murray is fifth on pro
football focus quarterback that you
would start your franchise with
now age of course is a factor in all of
this dak prescott is sixth
trevor lawrence is seven
justin fields eight
mack jones is nine
lamar jackson 10.
any issues
um
i i don't feel as good about any of
those as i do about herbert
and josh
[Laughter]
i i was surprised justin fields was up
there i mean that's
pretty elevated uh status for somebody
who's had basically one quarter of
really impressive football
yeah listen we did we did justin fields
uh twice this year and um and just
sitting with him talking with him
watching him on the field uh he has
everything that you're looking for it's
hard to evaluate in that situation that
he's had in chicago with the supporting
cast the coaching and everything the
tumult in the front office uh i i hope
that they get stable uh in that
organization and give him an opportunity
uh to see what he can really become but
uh all of those that you just mentioned
in that second tier have have questions
dan and um
so you know to start a franchise with
any one of those guys
um there's questions involved
paulie uh would you check has anybody
used tumult on this program before uh
just michigan guys dan oh okay so rich
eisen would probably use tumult right
jim harbaugh would not use that by the
way you think harbaugh flirting with the
nfl you okay with that as a michigan
grad
um listen i i'm always in favor of guys
maximizing their their value and it's
that time of year
what if you lose him brian
um listen if if we lose him um then we
lose him you know like i i'm not i'm not
one of those michigan grand i'm not like
i said that you know his his every
single day he wakes up you know whether
he's in a good mood or bad mood is how
michigan is doing and whether harbaugh's
staying or going that's not me well if
he leaves we'll find someone else
well weather and you know the problems
that that presents brady's probably
going to have high winds and rain
the the quarterbacks in buffalo are just
going to have the freezing cold there i
don't know if any other
teams are going to have to factor in
weather there but if i said you're
playing in wind and rain or you're going
to play in just bitterly cold weather as
a quarterback which one would you pick
yeah just give me the cold you know the
cold
isn't selfishly for a quarterback it's
it's really not an impact now it's an
impact for the guys catching that rock
hard ball
uh and it is slick but uh but no the
wind and the rain is just not a good
combination and
that i think of all the games that game
will be impacted most by the weather uh
we know the eagles want to run the ball
and i'm excited to watch that eagles
offensive line against the defensive
front for
uh for the bucks i mean vida veya and
jason kelsey what a great like if you're
a fan of football and you're watching
the games this weekend just watch
jason kelsey the center for the eagles
and vida veya now you know it's a
mismatch from a size standpoint but the
wily vet and kelsey and the position and
the leverage and all those things um
that's what i'm gonna be watching i know
everybody else gonna be watching you
know jalen hurts and tom brady and all
but but to me jordan mylata the left
tackle uh against jpp and shaq barrett
coming off an injury um i think you're
going to get a good shot from the eagles
they're not going to lay down and and
the bucks have some question marks that
need to be answered and we talked with
bruce ahrens twice this year
and he says listen
nobody's going to run the ball on us
okay all right well we'll see uh it's
gonna be a different challenge on on
this weekend how would you doctor up the
football in cold weather as a
quarterback
what would you use
despite deflating it then did you ever
deflate a football
uh yes actually uh you know if it gets
cold
um you want to take more air out of the
ball because the ball gets really hard
but how do you do that though
well you have a little you have a needle
and you take a little bit of the air out
of the needle you're not allowed to do
that you're not allowed to do now you
have somebody who does this for you
correct yeah the the the uh the guys the
equipment managers they're the ones that
take care of the ball all within the
rules dan completely within the rules
all of it
but you know you gotta you gotta get up
to that level you gotta get to that line
but you wanna be able to feel the ball
your hands are already frozen the ball
is frozen and it gets slick the only
thing that you can do is if you take a
little air you can squeeze the ball a
little bit easier and then you can feel
it better that's that's why quarterbacks
do that but did brady do anything that
other quarterbacks don't do
i don't think so no i mean i think i
think you're you're constantly trying to
find what works for you
um now you now there is that line that
you go up to and then sometimes guys
will cross over it um but you're always
trying to find that advantage but were
they checking back then
you know back then dan it was
interesting uh the rules were different
um there was a time period where you had
to take the balls
out of the packaging it had to be brand
new like out of the out of the box and
out of the packaging and i remember
uh i was so frustrated one time we were
playing a game tony corenti uh who's
still working
kent comes into the locker room and and
he was making sure that the balls that
we were using on offense were coming
right out of the box i'm like tony like
let let my guys just work them over
let's just brush them a little bit
because they come out with a film on
them they're really slick
and it's impossible to throw that ball
um and i and you know i think tom and
peyton got together and they kind of
lobbied the league to get rid of that
rule which was the dumbest rule uh that
we have ever had for quarterbacks and
for offensive play because you got guys
going back to throwing the ball slipping
out of their hands and nobody wants to
watch that
um so the rules have changed um and i
think it's in a good place now
but you know i look at this
and it just seems like somebody rational
will just say
um the quarterback can have the ball
that he wants
and the quarterback can have the ball
that he wants there's no advantage there
if there's no you know deception there's
no nothing it's this is how you want the
football for your team this is how you
want the ball for your team
doesn't that seem yeah logical
it does seem logical uh you know and and
um but you know how
this league is it's cookie cutter and
they want everything by the book and
they want everything the same and and uh
but you certainly dan could make a
logical argument that hey let the
quarterback have it however he wants it
but you didn't learn to cheat at
michigan you learned this when you got
to the nfl
who why do you use that word
to gain an advantage my bad that word is
so hard
as i said as i said and i was quoted
within the guidelines okay of course
okay that's my bad my
okay the game that we're going to be
talking about on tuesday is going to be
what
you know i think it will be the dallas
san francisco game
and i think it's like san francisco in
this game yeah listen i i think that um
you know everybody is kind of getting on
this bandwagon uh after the second half
of the season and what kyle shanahan has
been able to do
um listen the season did not start well
for them at three and five uh i think
that they have figured out who they are
listen this is this is a this is not a
trendy pick it's not a fad
um if you've watched this team and we've
we've done their games a couple times
um they are the team that will drag you
drag the opponent out to the deep end of
the water okay and they're gonna make it
gritty and nasty they're not gonna let
you play the kind of game that you want
to play if you're dallas you know spread
it out and throw the ball all over the
place
um they're going to see how long you can
tread water because they've been
treading water for eight weeks
and they know that they can live in that
environment um and so listen all the
pressure is on dallas listen you know
jerry
at home um everything that they have
done
um from a from a personnel standpoint
from a roster standpoint um there's all
the pressure on dallas and and this game
is not gonna be be pretty it's not gonna
be um i know everybody wants to talk
about micah parsons and about randy
gregory about russia in the past we're
getting to jimmy garoppolo that is not
what this game is going to be about
kyle shanahan is going to make it about
how physical are you going to play or
are your are your weakest players your
weakest tacklers on your defense who are
your corners right on every defense
trayvon diggs no you're not going to be
intercepting passes i want to see if you
can tackle debo samuel one on one jalen
ramsey got that test last week okay uh
anthony brown the other corner on the
other side do you want to tackle elijah
mitchell on the perimeter that that's
what this game is going to be about i
think
that's what people are going to be
talking about on tuesday
great stuff brian uh my best to leaves
in uh in louis and uh we'll be watching
on monday night
all right dan good to see you that's uh
brian griese he didn't cheat he just uh
within the rules within the guidelines